[Música]
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson supera un voto de confianza
promovido por su propio partido después
de que varios legisladores conservadores
enviarán cartas a un comité del partido
conservador manifestando su oposición a
la continuidad de su líder la votación
quedó de la siguiente manera el
mandatario británico obtuvo 211 votos a
favor también 148 en contra el primero
sólo necesitaba 180 para superarla y
pues como ya lo vemos superó esta moción
esta moción de censura que se produjo
tras las revelaciones sobre las fiestas
en diversas sedes del gobierno británico
durante la pandemia de kobe 19 escándalo
que se conoce con el nombre del pari
gates su victoria lo mantiene en el
cargo como primer ministro pero su
posición queda seriamente afectada de
manera negativa para ello entonces
quiero saludar a nuestro primero
invitado al día del steam durant
analista y director asociado insitió for
government de reino unido gracias a ti
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de francia 24 una victoria
matemática pero sin embargo no es una
victoria política porque johnson sale
debilitado tras esta votación dentro de
su propio partido team
bueno buenos dias la margen de la
victoria era muy estrecha no he ganado
ha ganado una gran victoria y es
interesante que en las cifras
ha ganado con 211 votos pero tiene una
mayoría en el parlamento de 80 votos así
que hay hay hay un
espacio entre los que apoyan al primer
ministro que es más el más pequeño que
la mayoría que tiene el parlamento y eso
significa que va a tener dificultades
con su programa de la legislación
legislación no sabemos si el partido a
seguir apoyándole en los otros votos en
el parlamento así estima hablemos
precisamente de el partido de los tories
su propio partido hay digamos un efecto
revuelta a un efecto de rebeldía dentro
del partido porque también continúan los
llamados a que boris johnson renuncia y
también como lo habíamos entrevista de
prensa como decían los titulares johnson
se está aferrando al poder
y bueno ya veremos yo de momento no creo
que que habrá otro
otro voto de otra moción de censura
creo que
lo que pasó ahí de verdad la
ah
la fuerza de el sentimiento del partido
contra
los diputados han mostrado que están
nos quieren o alguna gran parte del
partido no quiere que él siga como
primer ministro y eso va a hacer que va
a significar que
todos los todos los que quiere hacer va
a ser mucho más
digamos que una renuncia en el corto
plazo no está no está sobre la mesa
yo creo que no
ya ustedes han hablado de los de las
funciones de sensor centro-derecha me
moví thatcher pero entonces es diferente
él no va a renunciar no él no va a decir
bueno yo yo
excepto que he fallado en que voy a
renunciar él siempre va a estar en mí
hasta que alguien libia
usted tiene que irse así que yo es otra
situación a los otros de medida ahora
como están las cosas digamos con esta
división dentro de su propio partido
conservador o cómo queda el partido
frente a los otros parlamentarios
digamos cómo queda entonces el partido
conservador dentro de la cámara de los
comunes
bueno todavía tiene una mayoría pero ya
sabemos qué
140 150 personas de esta mayoría no
están a favor de watson son así que yo
creo que
a estos rebeldes es posible que trabajen
juntos con nosotros partidos con los
partidos de la oposición para para
mostrar a jones tenía su equipo así a
sus jugadores que hay que cambiar que
hay que hacer otras cosas que hay que
y hacer cosas diferentes y creo que
es muy fácil hablar de los votos y las
cifras y todo eso pero lo que importa es
que lo que hace en el país lo que hace
lo que haga el gobierno y creo que vamos
a ver que el gobierno no puede hacer lo
que quieran o no pueden lograr sus
objetivos porque siempre tienen que
estar hablando con los diputados siempre
tienen que decir bueno ustedes van a
juega nos en este voto o esté este voto
y no van a poder construir algo positivo
no van a poder mirar hacia el futuro
sino que siempre van a tener que ganar
cada voto cada día y el gobierno basta
para tener muchas con este resultado que
vemos ayer team de la votación de la
moción de censura se espera entonces que
boris johnson haga algún tipo de cambio
dentro de la estructura de su gobierno
bueno había dicho muchas veces que van a
querer cambiar las estructuras del
gobierno ha dicho que
ha tenido
mucho mucho cambio en su equipo en
downing street es posible que cambie
unos ministros o que
que dice a los diputados leales voy a
darle un empleo en un ministerio pero
no creo que esté estos cambios le
ayudarán creo que
el problema que tiene es que el mismo
hace estos errores y que sus diputados
no puedan el mismo no es que tienen
problemas con su programa de gobierno o
con sus objetivos bueno la mayoría de
los diputados no tienen problemas con su
gobierno es que tienen un problema con
boston ser y no puede cambiar el mismo
digamos que el pueblo si tendría
problemas es como digamos la percepción
como ven al líder al primer ministro
británico boris johnson además de cara a
los próximos comicios de junio que se
vienen en reino unido
y yo creo que sí que
la idea del partido conservador es que
voten siempre es muy popular que siempre
la gente te ama pero ya hemos visto que
si los encuentros y todo no es tan
popular como era y ahora
con
todo lo que pasó en bote gheit con esta
esta emoción ayer sí ya vemos que no
están no es tan popular y no es tan
especial o como era él también puede
pedir elecciones y entonces semanas
después de dos semanas tenemos dos
elecciones en distritos electorales
claro que ampliamente tenían diputados
conservadores pero lo que la mayoría de
los encuestas dicen que los
conservadores van a perder estos
estos distintos y el patio va a ver de
nuevo que no es tan popular como era